I think lack of belief isn't just a
problem for entrepreneurs I think it's
just everybody's problem it's my problem
I think your purpose comes from your
pain so right whatever you struggled the
most with is what you want to help other
people through and because I struggled
so much with believe myself I want to
help other people go through it and I'm
still not done the next Evan is on the
other side of even more belief
self-belief comes from doing difficult
things so the more that you do something
that you didn't think you're capable of
doing all of a sudden you say oh I can't
do it every time there's something hard
in front of you that then you say no to
you're reinforcing the belief that you
can't do something like that and every
time you say yes to doing it you start
to reinforce a new belief that you're
created so it's not just these one-off
moments it's the everyday battle for
everything like did you wake up and do
your morning routine did you work out
did you watch your video did you yoga
did you kiss your wife like whatever the
things are that are part of your routine
there are days when you wake up you
don't want to do it it's in those
moments where it really counts who are
you are you the kind of person who
follows through and does it because then
that starts to reinforce a positive
belief about yourself or you're the
person who says Ah you know I'm tired
I'm not gonna do it today that's okay
self-belief self-confidence self-respect
self-love I believe comes from doing
difficult things need motivation watch
the top 10 with believe Nation hey
what's up and Carmichael and I make
these videos because I need them because
I don't always wake up and feel
motivated to go take on the day and the
thing that saves me that helps me every
day is being around people who are
thinking bigger who are changing the
world and it gives me a little more
inspiration to go after my mission and
so I hope this video helps you go up to
yours today too so today let's learn
from me and my team's take on my top 10
rules of success enjoy
rule number two is create value if
you're just focused on creating value or
doing service you never know what's
going to come back in return
[Music]
right I I honestly have a hard time
connecting so this is maybe my internal
struggle Association I mean you can help
me with this so you know we've I wanna I
wanna change the world right solve the
world's biggest problem I want to hit
every human I know I'm not going to but
it it changes how I show up to the work
that I want to do things that have the
ability to scale so you know we've had
over 500 million people watch our videos
[Music]
know what that I can't I can't process
that I don't know what that means but
coming on and doing a show with you
grounds me to feel like oh Ashish likes
my stuff you know she hasn't been
inspired by some of my content you
telling me that that what I've done has
had an impact on you is more meaningful
in my heart than having three and a half
million subscribers on my YouTube
channel because I don't know how to
connect that so I I like to have that
balance in that I'm still going for the
growth because I want to change the
world but I get the most meaningful
connection from talking to an individual
entrepreneur who loves the content and
had a story to share rule number three
is find the right people did you have
that experience that you had to go clean
up your network or your circle of
friends or yeah I mean what I'm
introverted so I don't have a lot of
friends so that that time
beginning but I think it it for me it
wasn't like there was this one person or
group of people who are really negative
around me it was more just a slow
letting go and spending less time with
people that then it kind of Fades out so
it wasn't an intentional you're a
negative person and I'm not going to
talk to you anymore it was just I'm I'm
moving in this direction and you're
moving in that direction and we just
don't have as much in common anymore and
so
we just stopped talking and stopped
hanging out but it was never like this
awkward conversation of saying that yeah
you're out of my life and I think a lot
of people stay in relationships just out
of convenience and out of fear is that
just because you went to grade four with
them it doesn't mean you still have to
be friends with them in your adult life
you're probably if you're watching the
show Right audience you're they're
probably way ahead of ahead of their
friends already they're the most
ambitious people that they know and if
somebody is sucking energy from you
you probably don't want to spend as much
time with them and if it's family it's a
little harder you don't want to
necessarily just cut off your mom from
your life although some people do that
because it's the best thing for them but
it could also be limiting access to
topics it's like okay we're not talking
about my career because every time we
talk about my career it goes down this
crazy negative path so we're not talking
about that but we're going to talk about
these things that we know we can connect
on because I love you right and so
limiting access or could enough people I
think can be really helpful but it's
just paying attention to the energy that
you get from people
right I'm you know I met you earlier
this morning
I'm I'm coming out of this right we're
gonna have this interview I already have
more energy than when I start right like
we're gonna leave this and for me at
least I'm gonna have more energy than
when we start right so when you're
around the right people
it raises your energy absolutely I
totally agree with that and if I if
you're if I left an interview with
somebody I'm like I feel worse than I
did going in like okay I'm not going to
talk to that person again yeah right
yeah and so there's a lot of energy
suckers or energy vampires or it's just
paying attention to that consistently
and if you find the awkward part is if
you find good people who you really like
try to spend more time with them and so
I have a saying that I like to collect
good people
so when somebody asks what do you
collect you collect good people have it
right I don't collect I don't collect
baseball cards or stamps or I collect
good people
and it can be awkward especially for
introverts at the beginning it's like
when you find somebody at an event or on
a call or somebody you don't really know
very well but you just had great energy
that you leave and you're like man that
was awesome I I try to find a way to
spend more time with that person whether
it's just messaging on Instagram at the
start whether it's trying to set up a
coffee meeting to talk about our
businesses like
you be the one to reach out because
everybody knows somebody in their
Network who is a positive optimistic
energy giving person
you may not have a lot of those people
but there's one person you could think
of and it's probably not the closest
person to you it's probably a friend of
a friend or somebody met at some event
like but you can think of them find a
way to stay connected with them meet
them once a month for coffee connect
with them on Instagram and go back and
forth just like have more of them in
your life and watch your life start to
Ripple forward in a positive direction
rule number four is engineer your
environment what are your thoughts on
the idea that maybe that the lack of
self-belief really is just the problem
is exposure for some people yeah and and
we're around people who keep us stuck
like your environment has been perfectly
designed to keep you where you are and
the fortunate thing and you know going
2023 2024 is you can change it like your
the opportunities you have right now at
your age are so much better than your
parents at your age yeah like we have
the internet yeah we have YouTube all
the best mentors and teachers are there
like the information Nation now is
available the opportunities are
available you had to be crazy if my I'm
42 years old if I look at my dad when he
was 42 he would have to be crazy to be
an entrepreneur you have to be basically
unemployable crazy to start your own
company and it was really hard now
anybody can do it so the world has
changed and so if you don't like the
environment that you're in and the
people and the voices that are in your
head cool you can shift it you can now
choose to be around more positivity and
encourage people to really do an audit
of the friends in your life the people
in your life and also who you're
following on Instagram on YouTube the
various platforms when you watch YouTube
videos or you're on Instagram and you
put it down do you feel better about
yourself or Worse do you spend two hours
just kind of mindlessly scrolling cool
like unfollow all those people yeah
because there's lots of like Instagram
and YouTube are not the problem there's
lots of great people posting amazing
content your life can change by being
around the right people yeah so
consciously choose engineer who you're
going to be following and who you're
going to listen to
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is establish a
routine tell me about your daily routine
so I have a morning routine and an
evening routine that are fairly
consistent and then I have a daily
routine that's different than other days
so so one day a week to do different
things in terms of that kind of daily
routine that switches up
um switching costs are real you know
even even in mono tasking like we know
multitasking of of trying to do multiple
things at once but even monotasking to
do one thing at a time switching costs
are huge between jumping from one thing
to another so if I'm gonna jump from you
to then go and write my book to then
going and doing email to then go it's
just it's too much of a switch you know
for me to get into the zone of writing
my book I need 45 minutes just to get
back to where I was from the last time I
left off from it so I try to assign
different things for different days
now I'm I'm in complete control pretty
much of my calendar that may not be the
case for everybody but for what you can
control than being intentional about it
so for me Monday Monday is my mentoring
day with 40 people on my team I want to
be the kind of boss that when they come
in we make them a better human than if
they ever leave right so I spend the
whole day mentoring the people on my
team Tuesday is my YouTube day it's
content day I'm filming like if you do
not have time on your calendar to film
you're not going to film you're not
going to make the content if you wait
till you're inspired you're never going
to make anything so Tuesday is like
YouTube it's consistent it's in my
calendar every Tuesday I'm making
content Wednesday is my project day and
that is free it's open it's whatever I
want to work on because the over
scheduled entrepreneur usually ends up
hating their life for their business
because they never have time to work on
the things that that is new into their
company so my Tuesdays and Thursdays are
really jam-packed Wednesday in the
middle is completely open so yesterday
was a Wednesday I'm working on my book
next Wednesday my work on something
completely different and it doesn't
always have to have a practical payoff
it's just something new fun experience
creativity is messy so Wednesday's a
messy day Thursday is my public facing
day interviews podcast today's a
Thursday when we're recording this right
right so when we book these you know I
have 25 minutes on five minute break 25
minutes on five minute break so after
this I'm going into another 25 minute
session then the five minute break and
it's like my whole day gets filled up
doing other people's shows and podcasts
and it's it's just staying in the same
energy like the energy you're getting
now I'm naturally introverted and shy
people don't get that about me it
doesn't come across but the energy I'm
showing up for your show is the result
of the five other shows I've done before
getting to you right and I'm gonna then
take Ashish energy and pour it into the
next person yeah right so this you're
you're not um sucking my energy you're
feeding me energy that I'm then going to
pour into the person who comes
afterwards right so like staying in that
energy zone is really important that's
how the day flies by and you get into
flow instead of having to jump from one
thing to the next Friday's my CEO day
um and I started with CEO hours like if
I had one hour what would I do if I was
a CEO like whatever that means to you
the CEO of your business now what does
that person do and I moved it to be the
whole day so like working on the
business instead of in the business
and then apply for the weekend like
Saturday is fun day Saturday is fun
stuff to do with my wife at the family
not like we just got a new house and
there's insane amounts of work that has
to get done that's not Saturday Saturday
is what we're gonna do for fun new
restaurant Street Festival drive-in
movie theater hang out like whatever but
fun and then Sunday's family admin day
where that's the
doing the laundry and whatever and then
and then repeats again on Monday and
like that your you know your actions
have to map to your Ambitions you have
you have goals of what you want to
accomplish and not just like business
goals but a life what do you what do you
want to what does your dream life look
like and then you have to have it in
your calendar to do the actions
otherwise it just becomes you know a
hope so that's my yeah that's my I love
them
and it'll change and switch right yeah
it changes at the beginning I had nobody
on my team so I didn't have a a
mentoring day who was a mentoring nobody
so let's get to work now I have 40
people on my team so I need to have a
day focused on mentoring and so the
willingness this is like the willingness
to Pivot and change especially in
entrepreneurship because you learn and
grow right like entrepreneurship is the
greatest personal development course of
all time you're learning and growing and
improving so it's crazy to think that
how you start and what you're working on
now is still going to be the same thing
in three years like your business has to
Pivot and change and your calendar has
to Pivot and change as you change and
evolve as a human being so wherever I'm
not happy especially consistently like
if it's a couple days in a row of not
being happy
something is wrong in my calendar like
I'm just not doing the right things
anymore I need to make a change and if
you can catch it early enough then you
don't end up having this giant crisis
where you have to make this insane
change right because you feel you just
fell completely out of alignment with
yourself
Graham for example it's a lot of people
sharing all of their best moments it's
their highlight reel of their life and
all these awards that you want and the
Beautiful Photoshop Beach picture and
all that and I think there's still
definitely a lot of that and a lot of
people who are too afraid to ever show
any kind of weakness
um even some people in the personal
development space are like too afraid to
show their weakness and then some people
are very candid and upfront and share
everything and that becomes their brand
um you know if you look at Gary he's
he's very open about how he struggles
with candid uh being candid having
candid conversations
um Mel Robbins is very open to sharing
like her brand of personal development
is basically all the stuff that she's
trying to figure out for herself yeah
she says and then she she learns and
then she teaches uh so I think you know
authenticity is a big buzzword people
are throwing around I think it can
definitely help connect people to you I
think it just depends on who you're
following
um there's a lot of people who who come
off as perfect still and they they grow
they're following doing that and there's
a lot of people who lean into the other
side and show all the the warts and um
that attracts people as well
I love that showing all the warts
showing all the warts and and you get to
decide who you want to be right I think
ultimately you'll be happier if you show
the warts and the what you're insecure
about and like James alticher A friend
of the channel
um he liked to save her his podcast that
he basically thinks about what's the
what's the problem that he's most
embarrassed about right now that like
someone like him should have figured out
and then tell people about it
that you should have already figured out
by now and then and then tell people
yeah and and that makes him very
endearing that's why a lot of people
love him rule number seven is do what
you love Evan I find you so interesting
because you're an introvert and and
generally speaking introverts get energy
for being alone that's kind of like part
of it
um also call me out if that's wrong but
what's interesting is you get a lot of
energy from helping people which usually
in context is around people yeah so it's
just interesting thing with you where
it's like you keep saying you're an
introvert but then when we were meeting
you were like pretty chill and laid back
and then the second that we start
talking about you like it's like you
were taking the energy yeah from the
environment so it was just it's
interesting I don't know that I'll speak
on behalf of all introverts but you know
my own story would be I struggled with
this a lot
my biggest fight with my agent was like
you need to be famous Evan it's like I
don't want to be famous yeah why do I
want to be famous I want to be famous
and he's like I don't understand you
everybody I work with wants to be famous
like okay cool I don't know I don't want
to be fair and so we fought for years
until he said you don't understand you
know the the if you get more famous
people hear the message and it's always
been about the message and so
hanging out in most like I remember
being in San Diego this still happens
this is like late last year a couple
months ago in San Diego uh Grant Cardone
was doing this event on in San Diego and
it was on a boat and the boat was gonna
have like Tim Tebow and like all these
celebs and and you went on a boat cruise
and you come back and because it was
like three or four hours on the boat and
I'd have no way to get back if I didn't
like it I didn't go
right it's like oh three hours on a boat
and I have no way to get back what if I
hate it right it's like yeah like I need
an escape plan I gotta go
um but what I realized was introverts
love to serve yeah like we want to serve
too we want to feel like the work we do
has meaning and matters to people and so
that's what I lean in and focus on and
most conversations
do drain me if you want to talk about
the weather or I don't know what do
people talk about I I don't know what
people talk about I suck at all that
stuff I hate it it drains me like I
really I I do not like networking events
it drains me to no end I hate to
introducing myself I hate asking
answering like well what do you do all
of that like I never talk to the person
on the airplane next to me yeah all of
it zero uh but if you can hit on like a
couple of if you're an entrepreneur or
you love salsa dancing or League of
Legends uh we could probably have like a
really deep five-hour conversation and
so I think at least for me it may not be
for all introverts we love meaningful
deep powerful conversations and none of
the surface fluffy stuff and that's the
stuff that
um really will drain me and I'll avoid
yeah as much as possible yeah rule
number eight is ask for feedback when I
go to events I ask people to give me
advice and feedback the people who I
respect on my videos for example and
I'll always leave with hey tell me why I
suck tell me where it sucks
and I know it doesn't suck but what I'm
doing is giving them permission to be
honest
to say okay here's what I would actually
fix he'll say hey Evan it doesn't suck
but I would fix these you know one two
three things to get the real advice
they're not hiding the truth
but why am I able to do that well
because I'm grounded in knowing that the
stuff is good and I'm grounded in
knowing that I love the work that I'm
that I'm doing right so it allows for
the push to go off and do more the
problem becomes is like you're why are
you going to do more is it is it
grounded in in service and and kindness
and trying to help people is it grounded
in no because if I get that Lamborghini
it's gonna make me look good to people
who I don't care about right that was it
right there yeah right this is like
service but you have to feel connected
to the service you have to feel like the
thing matters so if you put out this
episode and five people watch it or five
million people watch it it's I would
tell myself that it's having an impact
and at least one person that even even
this even if you never I've had shows
where I'm like their first guest and it
never gets published right but hopefully
in something I say today maybe it moves
you Ashish forward and it has a little
spark because I've I've seen it enough
where like four years later five years
later eight years later we meet at some
event they say you know that thing you
told me back in 2022 dude that like
changed everything like I've seen enough
of that happen that it makes you realize
that this is really important that like
this work that I do to help really
matter rule number nine is stop wasting
your time we talk about James aldisher
something that he had mentioned on
Twitter one one day and that really
stuck with me was he added up all the
minutes uh in all the minutes which add
up to hours that we spend like watching
TV and being in traffic and being in the
restroom and being on Twitter and on
social media and checking emails and
texting people and it came out to this
ridiculous amount of hours per day and
then I think the question was posed like
you know imagine what you could be
creating instead of doing this doing
these other things and so to your point
you were able to crank this out in a
very short amount of time yeah and I I
started on a Tuesday we had our
Instagram live session on Tuesday we
finished at you know three o'clock and
the book is called momentum so
when she asks when are you going to
start well how do I start it next year
like it's called momentum I kind of have
to start like right now if I'm going to
call it momentum right yeah if I was
going to call it procrastination then
that's fine next year great uh so I had
to start right away and I got some words
done that day I got some words done the
next day on the Wednesday Wednesday is
my project day so it's completely open
so I had time to to work on things but
then the day after that was Thursday and
Thursday is my public facing day where
it's wall-to-wall interviews and
podcasts and like we're recording this
on a Thursday I don't know when it goes
live but it's wall-to-wall 25 minutes on
five minute break 25 like the whole day
it's like well I'm not going to get any
work done on on my book on Thursday like
there's no way and I write this like my
insecurities and concerns like I don't
want to lose momentum on the book
because I'm going to day three and the
zero time to do it and then on Thursday
two people cancel back to back last
minute
so now I have like this hour in the
middle of the day to actually do
something and so we think about like
what do we normally do if if something
happens if I couldn't make this podcast
for some reason Freddy I'm sick Freddy
what that happens people cancel
reschedule stuff always happens what do
we do in that time do we do we actually
be in tension with it probably I would
have I don't know check email check my
social media something probably not the
highest leverage because I had something
else planned that got last minute change
so I'm going to do something low value
but like I got an hour
let me write this is this is fantastic
right and I think we actually can find
these moments where we are wasting time
or doing low level activity
um where we stayed busy I think a lot of
entrepreneurs stay busy on things that a
lot of times don't matter like we do a
lot of work that's not very efficient
we're distracted by a bunch of things
and the actual outcome of that thing is
actually not that consequential versus
taking action a thing that actually
means the most to us so I think we have
those moments and again I had a full
schedule I got 40 something people on my
team I'm running multiple businesses and
agencies and I had no time planned to
write this book
on top of that we had a health scare in
the middle of it where my wife got this
lump above her breast that we have to go
to the doctor and like was insane she's
okay like I talk about that in the book
uh but that killed an entire day I'm
behind on everything and yet you still
got the book done 40 000 words
in five days and rule number ten the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is do it now I think you have to
trust your gut that's what they say yeah
because opportunities are coming like
that all the time but the problem is
they don't make sense a lot of times
because that shouldn't be coming to you
or you're not qualified or why am I
thinking about that or I didn't go to
school for that or that's not what I
should be doing right
and so we're missing all these
opportunities every day that are coming
by so you might there might be some
person walking down the street and for
whatever thought in your heads I should
I should say hi to them
why would I do that I don't say hi to
people I meet your friend I'm sure I
don't talk to people right exactly how
you doing
and you say you're an interview no but
like but that doesn't matter but I don't
do that that often but if I had the idea
for then I would right so it's just I've
had to train myself to just not think
about my thoughts and just do it and
just do it trust me Robin five four
three two one even faster than that
right like trust that great ideas flow
through you
I want to give that shot
now the caveat is if you're in a really
negative mood
that's where you need patience right
like if somebody cuts you off in traffic
oh yeah I'm gonna drive past that guy
just to see what he looks like right you
know you but that's that's where we
trust our impulses we will trust our
impulses when we're in a really negative
state of mind but we're in a really
positive one that's where we pause and
we need to flip it when you're in a
really negative State of Mind some bad
news happened
don't make a a rash call in the moment
right like something negative happened
the whole world has not Fallen apart
pause reflect sleep on it like come back
to it the next day and still see if you
want to do that thing or not but when
something great is happening and you're
in a positive spirit and an idea comes
to you
that's the time that you go do something
about it people are watching this
episode and like I want to go do blank
do it now because you're going to wake
up tomorrow and the energy will be gone
and you're starting over again and the
opportunity will pass you by
hey if you're present-minded you're
going to be a lot happier you're going
to be a lot more focused right if you're
just thinking about what you should have
done or what might happen to you you're
not actually able to be productive and
get stuff out right now in the present
and so the job becomes how do I stay
present and I think a lot of that is
accomplished through meditation for most
people if you're if you're in a state of
stress thinking about the regret of the
past or anxiety about the future I think
meditation can be incredibly helpful to
help you get back to present even just
focusing on your breath breathe in
breathe out even something as simple as
that can help calm me down and get you
back to the present moment which then
allows you to
be able to be productive uh solve the
problem be happy because you're being
more present so for me that's actually
quite easy I mean the present uh a lot
more than anywhere else and I used to
think it as a negative a friend of mine
used to make fun of me for having a bad
memory it's like you're such a bad
memory he's like and I later realized I
I don't have a bad memory I I one
remember what's important to me but two
I'm not living in the past like I don't
care about what happened I'm looking at
right now today I don't know what day it
is I don't know what day it is I don't
know I I know it's 2022 when recording
this I'd have to think about what month
it is
I don't know what I'm doing after
recording this video I don't know what I
did yesterday I don't know what I'm
doing tomorrow let alone once I press
stop on this video I am here with you
this is this is my entire attention is
making this video right now that's it
this is this is the present moment for
me and what I've discovered is
this is meditation
at least the the portion of it where
you're getting back to present moment if
that's one of the main benefits of
meditation then this is meditation for
me I'm only in the present moment right
now being here talking with you guys and
that's it
and I realized that most of my life is
lived like that yes I love planning for
where I'm gonna go but most of my time
isn't spent in planning it's in and
executing in doing and I have to look at
my calendar to see what I'm doing
tomorrow or what I'm doing when somebody
asks me on a Wednesday what's your
weekend going to look like weekend I
don't even know what I'm doing in the
next hour let alone what I'm doing this
weekend and when people ask me on a
Monday how was your weekend like I don't
know
that was that was that was yesterday
that was two days ago I'm I got stuff to
do right now I'm working on my life
right now and and not just work even
just enjoying even just life even just
me spending time with with my wife or my
son or on a trip it's like let's enjoy
this moment where we're at right now and
so if that's you I would introduce the
idea of hey that's a different
perspective shift like maybe you are
meditating right now and you might be
over judging yourself because if you're
in the present that's one of the biggest
benefits I want to hit more people I
want to serve more people like people I
want to spread the message I believe and
we're we're the one there is like it's
so possible and people need this so much
and like how do I make that happen what
is it that people need that you are
bringing to them what is the problem
that you were solving and for who yeah I
think the biggest problem Humanity faces
is a lack of belief
I think in themselves themselves yeah
it's like I think whatever cancer should
have been solved a decade ago but the
woman who would have solved cancer as a
manager at KPMG doing a job because she
never believed in herself enough right
that's my like we solve solve
self-belief you solve every other
problem in the world I have a bias
towards entrepreneurs because that's who
I love helping the most so that would be
like helping entrepreneurs believe
themselves more not that you know
teachers in government than whoever else
can't do it I know your background is
like corporate stuff as well it's like
great corporations have a huge role to
play I just default to entrepreneurs but
the problem I'm trying to solve is
helping people believe in themselves
more I think the way to do that is
content at scale people get to learn
from you today and learn to have more
self-belief even though like one-on-one
time with you would be insanely
expensive but my journey hopefully they
can learn a little bit as well through
this session so that's what I'm trying
to solve and for who you have Michael
Jordan level genius at something you you
are the greatest the greatest in the
world at something
and it's probably not what your parents
did or what you went to school for
it's sitting here somewhere deep buried
and you don't believe that you can do it
but until you actually lean in on what
you have Michael Jordan ability genius
at until you actually start doing it
you'll never live the life that you're
capable of you'll you'll constantly be
doing
what other people want you to do living
up to other people's expectations
meanwhile knowing that you're capable of
more I often get into fights uh maybe
not fights discussions maybe arguments
with people about when they're making
YouTube videos for example thought
leaves I'm I'm deeply passionate about
helping more thought leaders get onto
YouTube I want to see your message out
there because I believe that your
message can change the world I think
your message can impact people's lives
of people like you who you used to be
they need to hear your message and
you're you're too scared to get it up
there and one of the biggest
complaints are one of the biggest
objections people have is well I don't
know how to edit I don't know how to
film and what they end up doing is you
spend 20 minutes making a video
recording it and then five hours editing
it
what you're doing there is training the
wrong skill
if you want to make a video like this
right
you're going to sit in your car I'm
still just making this video off of my
phone right I just have like can you see
in my glasses maybe you can see look
I've got a there we go this is cool look
I've just got a little mini handheld
whatever tripod I guess a selfie stick
more like it and in my phone that's how
I'm filming this video that's it sitting
here in the car while my wife is in
Costco shopping and getting some awesome
food for us
if you spend 20 minutes making a video
filming it recording it and then five
hours editing it
you're just training the wrong skill
you'll never get great at the thing that
you have Michael Jordan level ability at
now if you said your ambition is to be
the world's greatest editor that's
different congratulations you're doing
it you're doing it but if you want to be
a thought leader a speaker an expert you
want to you want to learn to make videos
and be the front facing person then
spending 20 minutes on something to
actually improve your skill that's
improving your skill making the video
but five hours editing it you're just
not wasting time but you're you're
stealing from your opportunity you're
stealing from your ability you're
stealing from your best self
okay well what do I do Evan what how do
I how do I then create I don't want to
put up something that's bad
thing that gets you there is actually
getting great at your skill the Michael
Jordan level skill
I'd rather you spend five hours
making a video doing it again and again
and again and again and again and again
and again so you don't need editing
that you're so good at the thing that
you don't need at any
because that's a skill that will serve
you for life
because when you go on stage
you don't get to edit yourself right
there's no second takes when you go on
TV and you're being interviewed when you
go on people's podcasts you're being
interviewed if you're you're teaching
yourself that you're only good when
you're edited
and that's not your Michael Jordan level
ability planning doesn't count
planning strategizing making ideas that
doesn't count where you're going to grow
doesn't count you got to do
you got to send an email you gotta make
a piece of content you gotta post
something you gotta follow up with
somebody you have to create you got to
make
instead of just living in your head
right that's how you tell the difference
plan is just living in your head model
structured business plans ideas it's
it's amazing I love it I could be there
all day long
but you won't have any kind of impact
just staying up in here do every single
day adopt a mindset that you need to do
on a daily basis you can't feel grateful
and sad at the same time you can't feel
grateful and upset at the same time you
can't at the same time feel grateful and
hurt
vengeful rage you can't gratitude is the
opposite emotion the opposite expression
of all of those things so whenever
you're feeling low down negative hurt
upset the answer is gratitude
I don't like staying in
negative emotions for too long the only
one is grief you know I think the only
one that I
let happen is grief because I think you
just have to work your way through it I
don't want to trick myself out of grief
because
you're feeling it for a reason I don't
actually think it's a negative emotion I
think you have to just work your way
through it but everything else upset
anger hurt jealousy rage think about all
the other negative emotions that you
experience I don't want to stay in them
for too long they don't serve me they
don't serve you they don't allow you to
show up as your best self and so the
fastest way out is gratitude because
there's always something that you can't
be grateful for it's just a perspective
shift if I was sitting here in the car
feeling upset or feeling sorry for
myself or down on myself uh I can always
think back to I used to make 300 bucks a
month and feel like I wasn't doing
anything
that I was bringing no value that wasn't
contributing to anything
and now I get to I get to sit in this
car I get to sit in this car
right that little shift can make all the
world of difference I was talking to
Jeremy yesterday on my team and Jeremy
is an entrepreneur I invested into
what 18 months ago I guess he used to
have a job working at a grocery store
hating his life knowing who's capable of
more earning minimum wage
and just not liking what he was doing at
all and now he's he's built over half a
million dollar business a year
doing YouTube Consulting based off of
what I teach them teach them taught him
taught him and continue to teach him you
know he's got a half million dollar plus
business now and we're talking yesterday
and it was a little down because
you know the client who left him and and
that happens right Andy client service
business you get bad news clients
believe you you will at some point
underperform you will disappoint people
that's gonna happen and that and my job
is to help give more perspective to say
dude
it's okay you're you're still great
look at what you've built in the past 18
months look at where you were it used to
be a grocery store clerk now you're
working with amazing people helping them
build their channels getting paid insane
amounts of money compared to what you're
used to like how much money do you have
in your bank account compared to where
you were 18 months ago how much more
fulfilled are you in the work that
you're doing right now compared to where
you used to be 18 months ago right how
much of your world has changed so don't
get too down because the down doesn't
serve you this whole seriousness versus
playful thing I agree that it's
important to be playful I think smiling
is great I think having a happy
optimistic positive way of thinking
about things is really important
especially as entrepreneurs because we
have to deal with so much crap and so
much pain so much misery so much
rejection so much other people's
negativity around us that if you are not
playful if you are not joyous then it's
really really hard to keep going on your
mission and it's ultimately why a lot of
people stop and they quit they get
consume by the negativity and they have
to leave it and go off and do something
else that being said I also think
there's a time for seriousness I think
it can really help you I think it can
help Focus you I think it can help drive
you forward on your mission the way I
see playfulness and seriousness are two
sides of the same coin I think you need
both I think they're not opposite of
each other I think they complement each
other I see it as the same thing as
ambition and gratitude I think you need
to be really ambitious I think it's
important to have big goals and set a
life for yourself that you want to go
off and accomplish and keep striving to
do it and I think it's important to be
really grateful for everything that you
already do have you are spoiled you are
lucky you are so fortunate just to be
alive just to be living in your country
just be able to watch these YouTube
videos there's so much that you have to
be grateful for that you don't even
recognize and so I think both of those
serve each other I think if you are just
overly ambitious and never are grateful
I think it just leads to a really dark
place I think it's never enough and it
just becomes all-consuming and I think
if you're only grateful all the time and
have zero ambition then that's a happy
life but you're not helping others
you're not serving others you're not
fulfilling the potential that you have
inside yourself and so I think of them
as both being necessary I think you need
both of them I think one Standalone
doesn't help you get to where you need
to go and so I see that as the same
thing as playfulness and seriousness I
see them as two sides of the same coin I
think you need both of them at different
times to help you go off and be that
best version of yourself I'm sure
thinking about okay I'm not great at
these things
but they need to get done
right some of these things have to get
done first you want to eliminate if it's
if you don't have to do it then don't do
it this there's some things that you're
doing that actually don't matter
there's something that I'm doing that
don't matter that you think matter but
then when you analyze like that doesn't
even matter nobody even cares if I do
that thing or not
right just eliminate it don't don't give
it to somebody else if it shouldn't even
be done in the first place you eliminate
it
then you automate it so automate is look
for ways to do it through software
through technology through tools
anything that I'm I'm doing multiple
times like okay how do I
how do I make this more automatic so
that I don't have to be doing this all
the time
and if you can't eliminate it and you
can't automate it then you delegate it
and delegate is you give it to somebody
give it to somebody who that's their
Michael Jordan level genius
editing these videos I have an amazing
team you know Christina hi Christina is
amazing and that's her Michael Jordan
level genius she makes amazing videos
she can edit way way way better than I
ever could let alone than what I can do
right now
and when you find people who they are
the Michael Jordan level of the thing
that you suck at that's when you can
really start to explode now you might be
you might not be able to afford them yet
so what can you do well one you get
uh people who can volunteer who can
maybe do some kind of barter like
entrepreneurship is about being
resourceful
what can you offer them and what can
they offer you what kind of trade can
you make if you have no money what kind
of trade can you make instead of saying
well I just I don't have money to hire
somebody so I'm just going to do it
myself you have to start being more
strategic
you have to start thinking okay what am
I what am I so fantastic at what is your
Michael Jordan level ability and how can
that be of value to somebody else that
in exchange for me helping them they can
help me with this thing
that's how entrepreneurship works
the ones who really really win they're
not the ones who do it all themselves
they're the ones who are resourceful to
find ways to bring on a team
right the ones who are Ultra successful
are not doing everything themselves they
they're willing to go and do it if they
have to
they're willing to do it if they have to
but they're not default thinking I'm
going to do everything myself schedule
your due time what I want you to do is
plan for one hour every single day if
you're an entrepreneur one hour every
day where you are doing pick a time
ideally I think morning like if you get
in at nine to nine to ten first hour of
the day but if it's not then block in
the account this is important this is
what will change your life this is what
will change the trajectory of your
business if you are stuck constantly and
just responding to people and planning
perfectionist mode do time right we said
do a daily point number one now you got
to schedule it in just have an intention
won't do anything if you're not actually
taking action on it right you're not
doing the thing that you promise to do
you're not doing the doing the progress
that you will make
the closer you get to your goals will be
a reflection of what you are putting in
your calendar what you're actually doing
so I want you to schedule one hour today
of due time every single day we're going
to be making something and pushing it up
to the world my biggest fear to
disappointing people my biggest fear is
I'm gonna let people down you're going
to watch my my thing my video my
interview and feel like it was a waste
of your time that Matthew would feel
it's a waste of time that you feel it's
a waste of time that's always my biggest
fear is that I'll still show up but it's
going to be a disappointment to people
and so my strategy used to be prepare
prepare prepare prepare prepare prepare
prepare prepare
prepare like crazy
my strategies always prepare over
prepare have everything super prepared
and
what ended up happening was a solid B
interview
because I just asked the questions that
were on my list
there was there was nothing risky
but it wasn't a great interview
I mean I was just asking typical
questions
I didn't offend anybody
but it was never anything great
and so what I had to learn to adjust and
this is something that Dr Tess helped a
lot with was figuring out you know what
all I need to do is find the one angle
what's my one angle what's the One path
what's the one series of questions that
I want to ask and then pull on that
thread and trust that my curiosity will
take over
so
with Matthew
he wanted to promote his book I didn't
have enough time to read the book fully
before I came in I'm a super slow reader
and I got it shortly before the
interview I'm a visual learner so what I
did was I watched his other interviews
I went to the other interviews that he
had talking about the book
and what I did was I thought okay what
would I ask that's different from these
guys or what's the question that they
didn't ask as a follow-up like oh that's
a good line of thinking what's the
follow-up oh I wish they asked that
question and I made a note of this is
the question I want to ask and the thing
that
caught my attention the most was him
talking about when he took his uh
sabbatical from acting
um it wasn't it was kind of a force
sabbatical he didn't want to do romantic
comedies anymore and ended up going 20
months without acting and he considered
going to other careers
in the job that he was looking at as
other careers they were see if I can
remember there was
a grade four teacher there was a high
school football coach there was a
musical conductor Orchestra conduct an
orchestra there was be an animal
Wilderness guide
and I think there was one more
and I asked him these things they all
seem to have teaching in common
whether they're teaching kids or adults
it's a wide range of different
potentials but they're all teaching if
you're a conductor you're still teaching
professionals if you're the animal the
guy you're teaching about the animals
like
where does that threat come from
and he said I never thought about that
he didn't quite know how to answer that
question and at the very end of our
interview 20 minutes later he thanked me
for
bringing that up and he's gonna go keep
on thinking about this whole teaching
angle and why that's in him and where it
comes from I'm gonna keep thinking about
this condominator of me wanting to be a
teacher thank you that's a much better
interview
as asking a question that I don't know
what the answer is going to be
and it's my genuine curiosity
and so there's always that line in
between of
the thing that you are preparing for and
preparing for preparing for to then give
you the freedom to be open
and curious
I do a lot of work with Tony Robbins
agency
his PR agency and and we brought a whole
bunch of different people on my channel
to do different interviews with and one
of the things that the the head person
there
always says about me which is super
humbling is just the Curiosity and
energy that I have
to show up for the interviews and it's
shocking to hear that because it's like
I don't I never thought of myself as a
great interviewer but all I have to do
when I'm preparing is find the angle
like what do I actually why am I genuine
and energetic because I actually care
about this thing from them I have to
find their story and research them
enough to know the angle that I want to
use to find the thread to pull on
and then I just let go and trust that
I'm going to do a good job get clear on
what you want what do you want make it
super clear you can't just want a better
life what does that look like get super
clear on what it is that you are going
after write it down one sentence make it
clear for yourself make it clear for the
people around you make it clear for
anybody who comes in contact with you
say hey what do you want this this is
what I want I have absolute focus and
when people look at you and say you're
never going to do that look at where
you're coming from that's okay because
you have direction right the world gets
out of the way for the person who knows
what they want you need to get clear on
what you want get it down to one
sentence focus on service will
immediately
reduce anxiety reduce your stress and
reduce the lack of self-love that you're
feeling
okay so that's service great but how do
I serve whom do I serve well that comes
back to your why
your why is your purpose your purpose
comes from your pain the people who
you'll love helping
for the rest of your life
are the people who currently are who you
used to be
think about who you used to be think
about what you used to struggle with the
demons that you were fighting the hole
that you are in you are much better now
than who you used to be think about your
most painful moment not physical pain of
breaking I broke my neck in two spots
that was my most physical pain but not
that emotional pain when did you feel
the most worthless when did you feel the
most worthless as a human being when was
that for you
and then recognize that there are
millions of people right now who are
struggling with the same thing they feel
worthless they feel the same
worthlessness that you felt they're
struggling with the exact same thing
exact same thing that you're that you
struggled with right now they're in the
depths of it you've come out you're not
where you want to be you still got a lot
of growth left you still want to improve
you still want to do a lot more
but you're way better off compared to
who you used to be
and sometimes it helps to just think
about who you were 10 years ago five
years ago or maybe you already know the
moment in your in your life that was the
worst for you there are millions of
people who are suffering with that same
thing right now
your path is to help them
your path is to show them hope your path
is to give them the strategies to get
out
because a lot of them they're so low
they're so negative they're so hopeless
that they won't listen to an Evan
Carmichael or Marie forleo or Tony
Robbins
former you didn't want to listen to an
Evan Carmichael
a guy motivational self-help BS
he doesn't understand me
but you know what to listen to you
they'll listen to you because you are
one of them
because you know exactly what they're
dealing with exactly what they're going
through and exactly how to get out of it
because you tried a million different
things a million different things how
many things did you try to get out of
the hole that you were in how many
things how many times did you try how
many times did you get up and fail and
get back up and fail and try a new thing
that was supposed to be the answer and
then fail didn't work again and almost
give up and almost give up and almost
give up and then you finally found
something one thing that maybe didn't
even seem like a big thing and it and it
worked
holy cow this is working I'm getting
momentum I I'm starting to change and
starting to see results
and now you're here congratulations
you made it
you are an impossibility
right you being here is impossible to
former you you 10 years ago look to
where you are right now is like that's
not possible I won't be there I can't do
that it's an impossibility
but you did it
[Music]
and so that's your job is to go back and
show all the people who currently are
who you used to be that it is possible
that they can do it that you're just
like them
that you were them that you might have
struck struggled and suffered struffled
is that the combination struggled and
suffered is truffled you struffled
worse than them
worse than them and yet and yet here you
are you made it
helping somebody
Who currently is who you used to be
that's the game that's the juice that'll
fill you up for the rest of your life
one of my greatest uh fears right now of
all time actually is disappointing
people I hate disappointing people it's
my greatest fear of all time I don't
want to disappoint people the idea that
I would get in front of a group and
disappoint them is is life-shattering to
me I hate that I hate wasting people's
time and so I'm on this tour right now
I'm in San Francisco I'm doing 23 cities
over 90 days
and I'm scared
because I'm scared I'm going to
disappoint people and it's not just one
event I get to get up every four days
and potentially disappoint people again
your heart goes boom boom boom boom boom
you have to do it
and now just the fact that I'm out doing
it regardless of if we have amazing
results or not just me doing it just me
trying it makes me feel great about
myself
and so you need to find the same thing
for you what is a challenge that is
worthy of you that if you got up and
every day tried your best you would
eventually win at it that you're not
going to tie yourself respect to you
crushing it immediately if you get a
victory right away you should have
started it three years ago if you get up
and you make a YouTube video in your
first one and it's amazing you actually
suck like you should have started that
video three years ago you're supposed to
suck at the beginning you always suck at
the beginning any new skill that you
want to learn you're not going to be
very good at it at the start that's how
it's supposed to work but if you tie
your self-respect your self-worth your
self-love to you getting up and doing
work every single day that makes you
proud that says I am proud of myself
today for the effort that I put in I
guarantee you you will not just love
yourself you will produce amazing things
for yourself for your family and for the
world your success is habits what you do
on a regular basis is what you're going
to accomplish you can eat a chocolate
bar and be on a diet and not get fat but
if you're eating a chocolate bar every
day you're gonna get fat you're not on a
diet anymore
similarly if you eat salad once a week
it's not enough right you are what you
consistently do your success comes from
doing habits and entrepreneurs are
typically great starters but not great
at being consistent and that's the
problem
working your face off for for 48 hour
stretch isn't going to do anything for
you
it's every single day working even if
it's only an hour a day that dream that
you have that business that you wanted
to start that business that you want to
take to the next level it could be there
it could have been there already it
could have been there already the
problem is you've been sitting on that
idea for three months six months four
years without doing enough on it little
tiny starts it's not enough every day
I'm talking every single day making
progress towards you actually
accomplishing that thing you want that
life you have to do it every day
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome pretend
more amazing rules from Brendan burchard
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there the habits that
everyone wants to talk about in the
popular literature or books is like you
know these small habits are Atomic
habits or automatic habits or
unconscious habits those are valuable
those are very important but high
performance requires deliberate habits a
deliberate habit